guys the csgo major has been cancelled
no this is not a drill we got the
official news yesterday and although I
think a lot of us saw it coming doesn't
mean it sucks any less and hey you want
some more bad csgo news well the former
heroic then fun plus Phoenix now heroic
again guys are out on their ass after
being completely screwed over at least
Australis got what they wanted
[Music]
alright guys you may have noticed things
look a little different around here and
that's because like everyone else at the
score eSports I'm working from home to
stop the spread of covet 19 but rest
assured all the great content you're
used to seeing won't be slowing down not
even a little bit now let's get back to
talking about the major because as most
of you know by now there won't be one in
May the Rio 2020 csgo major will instead
be taking place in November and it will
be the only one of this year
and while ESL's official statement on
the matter categorizes this as a
rescheduling the fact is we're only
getting one major this year which means
one is cancelled whether you want to say
it's the first or the second major of
the year that's getting canceled well
we're talking about six of one and half
a dozen of the other
same [ __ ] and this is just the latest in
a string of postponements and
cancellations in eSports due to
coronavirus ESL pro league season 11 and
flashpoint have been forced to go online
and outside of csgo League of Legends
and overwatch have been even more
adversely affected now as far as the
actual decision to scrap the major goes
honestly it was the only possibility I
don't know what it's like where you guys
are but in most of the world things are
on complete and total lockdown and
large-scale social gatherings or a big
no-no we knew this was coming
unfortunately knowing it's coming
doesn't really make it feel any better
not only do we not get to watch top tier
csgo in May but think of all the
different storylines that are lost
not as Vincere for one a team that came
hot out the gates in 2020 when a lot of
teams like astral sent Team Liquid did
not serve us is - and it's going to be
simple and flamey-o just seem to be
taking matters into their own hands
ladies and gentlemen there it is your
champions all gonna be Navi at that 3-0
clean sweep in the grand final this is a
legit team I mean can we be honest here
this was simples major to win the
greatest counter-strike player to ever
do it and a global pandemic takes his
major away come on man and look I know
I'm talking about it like he already won
it and with a major you never know but
still I just feel bad for the guy now
while axing the first major of the year
is a bummer there is a silver lining
here the November major will be the only
one of this year and it will have
doubled prize pool of 2 million dollars
that's the biggest ever for a major look
I'm not saying we're the International
just yet but this might be an opportune
time to test how the csgo audience
reacts to one single yearly major event
that means everything and has a huge
prize pool a lot of other sports do
revolve around one mega competition that
means everything in a calendar year and
we've talked a lot in the office about
whether or not that would work for CS I
know for example Demetri one of the
score you sports resident DOTA heads
thinks that valve should implement the
system not just in DotA but in CS as
well now I like the two major system
however I got to admit if they start
doing compendium battle past
crowdfunding stuff and we get a 30
million dollar major hey I'm in now this
wasn't the only high popping piece of
csgo news recently either we learned
that fun plus Phoenix the org that is
currently the world champion in League
of Legends pulled out of csgo in the
most base palm inducing way humanly
possible see it all started about two
weeks ago when the Chinese org
apparently bought the Danish roster off
of heroic and entered flashpoint and by
the way they joined flashpoint has a
partner team which means they paid or
would have to pay two million dollars to
get into the league then we learned that
a straw 'less had done a deal for essa
tag one of the fun plus Phoenix guys
except that the deal was with heroic
which means that essa tag was former
heroic then pumpless Phoenix then heroic
and now futurist Rallis anyways
apparently the deal between fpx and
heroic wasn't even done yet despite the
fact that they had played games under
the fpx banner in flashpoint and the
astrology l-- well that basically killed
the whole thing that's according to the
folks at hltv and nel and that was the
end of fun plus phoenix in csgo they
have since deleted every reference to
that team and to csgo on their social
media ending two weeks of glorious
history in the world's top FPS eSport
okay
[Music]
but here's the shitty part the players
are now completely screwed heroic had a
deal to play in ESL pro league they gave
that up to play in flashpoint now the
players can't do either it sucks and if
you watch the video Katy and posted on
it well you can see how gutted he really
is I know me and my teammates too sir
gussets we've been fighting very hard to
try and get this but in one of these two
French antiques so through a pandemic
global pandemic we travel across the
globe we out of her homes out of our
comfort zones I don't think I've ever
been this mistreated in my entire life
this really hurts cuz Katy is like the
nicest guy in real life about a year and
a half ago I interviewed him at IEM
Chicago and he was one of the hardest
working best interviewees in the room
when you work events you remember stuff
like that now on the bright side
astrology and essa tag means that come
June we're gonna see how a six-man
roster and csgo can really work now I
don't know how exactly a straw Louis
plan to use him they might want him to
be a substitute for individual players
who don't want to go to entire events
and need a break from competitive but
they also might use him as an in series
substitute between individual Maps and
yes you can do this in ESL and and blast
according to their rule books shoutouts
to former ESL referee me counselor
Winsky for confirming that so why is
this cool well if it works an
astrologist playing some 4d chess with a
six-man roster this could be the new
roster meta but it is it is tough
schedule so of course that was like the
main reason for us doing it but I can
definitely see some some potential
Patrick will be an integrated part of
our of our playing style like it will be
part of practice and I think it's ideal
if you have a guy a bit tired here there
then PASOK can swap in the purpose of it
is that we want to make sure that people
can last as long as possible and then we
don't have any like mental fatigue
because you know as I said before this
it's off schedule I mean substitute
players are used effectively in other
eSports
why not CS too and with eight months to
go until the next major well Australis
have plenty of time to practice with six
guys
for Rio what am i doing in isolation I
mean I'm keeping busy we're working from
home so that's you know a good chunk of
my weekday time been playing some war
zone
I always got tons of side projects going
on so I'm missing outside though I
haven't been outside in like four days
getting worried Oh also I set up workout
equipment in my kitchen all I can do are
pull-ups dips push-ups I have one
dumbbell it's 30 pounds I have a
stretching bar that's all I have those
those three things so yeah I mean leg
day is just just not gonna happen